okay Shoji to just made a massive roster
announcement and the result is sieges
first bona fide super team Fabien is out
virtue and citizen are in and what was
once the most strategic squad in siege
has since become a group of full flex
fraggers here's the thing though
everybody's on Twitter reddit freaking
out about whether these guys are gonna
live up to the g2 name and I only have
one question who the hell is gonna play
[Music]
okay so what is it that makes this
probably the single most momentous
roster move in the history of siege well
for that we need context thankfully my
dear friend Keith mr. TMZ himself has
decided to take a day off from streamer
news and let me bless y'all with some
eSports talk before we go any further I
just want to let you guys know if you
are at all interested in seeing more
don't at meas about a GE gamer topics
like Rainbow six subscribe to the
channel also like the video and let us
know in the comments what are six topics
you think we should be covering now if
you know anything about seeds you know
the G two are in the immortal words of
in Tarot the best team that has ever
played Rainbow six he needs to get into
the site and keep in mind in a four be
one
[Applause]
the first team to repeat as defecting
means the problem is that over the last
year or so they've really struggled to
perform they didn't make it to two
consecutive pro league finals they fell
short at the Raleigh major and failed to
qualify for the Invitational five
[ __ ] times so as a result they've
been shuffling their roster around a lot
so by the time it will be soft got
around to giving them a pity invite to
the 2020 Invitational since by their
lights bobbing and the boys still
deserve a chance to defend their title
the community was pretty convinced that
g2 were launched here I don't want to
get invited sir getting invited is
[ __ ] but it's like oh they're so bad
you couldn't qualify here's an
invitation dude I have too much honor
like I don't think we should be there
the thing is against every expectation
they actually put up a pretty
respectable result they topped their
group and even though they didn't make
it very far in playoffs they showed the
world that Fabien still had some cheeky
a strats obviously see it's a chunk of
pig I know there I think that's a bit of
a debate
he's Lawrie we surely gonna see yeah
okay we're gonna say Trancas trap des
the crazy thing is that just a few weeks
after invite it was announced that
Fabien the mastermind behind all of g2 s
domestic success had been benched the
even crazier thing is that apparently he
asked to be benched we'll get to that
for now let's talk about Gigi now you
think that in losing Fabi and Gigi would
be looking for a new in-game leader
someone to fill the shoes of the
self-titled best player in the world but
to everyone's surprise they didn't want
a strategist they wanted a [ __ ]
legion of Ash mates now whether it's
because they couldn't find someone to
fill Fabien shoes or because they didn't
even bother to try g2 enlisted the help
of pretty much the two most individually
talented fraggers in the world who
aren't already playing for top tier
rosters the first is virtue an
up-and-coming Australian aim God who g2
nabbed from fnatic the team to knock g2
out of the upper bracket at si the
second was citizen now next to psycho
citizen is pretty much the most
mechanically terrifying player in the
whole of Europe he helped Navi secure a
parolee championship back in November
and has apparently spent
every waking second of his career
dreaming of joining g2 now to be clear
it is not surprising the g2 were able to
nab star players at a moment's notice
they're like the Yankees of siege they
wait until other teams breed and nurture
top two your talent before swooping in
and stealing it for themselves what was
surprising is that they decided to go
with a frag around to go from basically
the most big-brained roster ever to a
shamelessly stacked super team and in
typical g2 fashion they couldn't help
put a meme on themselves a little bit
the question of course is whether
they'll be able to succeed on skill
alone whether they'll sort of the top or
like so many other super teams I'm
thinking team secretive ti5 or faze clan
literally at any point ever crash and
burn that said there is reason to think
that a frag heavy roster could do
extremely well in the current climate of
competitive siege
look at TSM for instance you've got bolo
achieved Merc and geo four of the
dankest GN disher's in all of Na and
POJO who's you know they're babysitting
support the second one we'll find him
that's a frag onto the back a Pinot from
bolo no on the side of that LMG another
for bolo down goes Giulio and TSM
seemingly have been able to start
catching the breaks and it's a one
before and a zero before map number one
TSN routinely fail to get walls open dry
peek everything and somehow finished
third at invite similar to how csgo
shifted towards a more frag flex heavy
meta in and around 2015 it is starting
to feel as if siege is becoming more and
more of a fraggers paradise they want to
play that way because it looks good the
problem is that that causes a lot of
frustration both for the player doing it
and the player receiving it it like it
really pays off quickly if you get away
with and it feels good when you do and
then you can put a clip up you can you
know you're the hero of the day if you
got that 3k rushing in society and while
it is difficult to imagine putting all
of this star power on one roster and
have the
do anything but [ __ ] excellence it is
impossible to overstate how huge the
expectations are around this team
whether they'll be able to live up to
them I don't know we'll have to wait and
see
as for Fabien his departure from g2
marks the end of an era the greatest
reign of tyranny that siege has ever
known and his split from Penghu it's
probably the most monumental roster move
ever still in spite of what the reddit
analysts would have you believe Fabien
is far from finished
take it from me someone who looked into
his eyes in Montreal and asked him about
his future this guy is on one he told me
that he would never ever stop trying to
become the best and I believed him you
don't even have to finish that question
for me to answer it I would never lose
my motivation to be the best I believe
in myself I wouldn't be here if I didn't
think that I lost the best it doesn't
matter what I think when I go onstage if
I think that I'm not the best guy when I
go into a duel I'm not gonna win it in
terms of why he left it's hard to say
apparently it's because the team dynamic
wasn't so great following their loss at
invites naturally the community has
already started to speculate as to where
he's gonna end up
he said he'll consider leaving Europe if
the offer is spicy enough and I for one
I'm hoping that it becomes the first
major European player to migrate over to
North America if we're going full eyes
emoji I'm thinking evil geniuses that
said as of right now there's no
indication that even Fabien knows where
he's gonna end up since his initial
plans seem to have actually fallen
through so until we actually hear
something and until we get to CG to play
there's not much else to say when I know
more so will you how many good nights do
I give out a night quite a few quite a
few quite a few yeah it's because I play
smoke though so I'm an SMG 11 main so I
spawn peak with the SMG 11 and whenever
I spawn peak with the SMG 11 I always
toss an all chat GN but the SMG 11 is
the best gun in the game and it's like
highly it's very hard to use very that
very very very unstable recoil but if
you I'm like I have like a religious
obsession with the weapon like I'm a
disciple of the SMG 11 it's the only gun
I use only I play sledge on attack so I
can just use the SMG 11